quand on a quand on a plusieurs cas et
qu'on a pas à trouver le casero et qu'on
n'a pas identifié tous les cas contacts
on est obligé de faire un confinement
c'est à dire les gens ne sortent plus
les écoles sont fermées
les spectacles sont fermés les gens ne
vont plus à l'hypermarché etc enfin ils
sortent plus quoi c'est la seule façon
de d'essayer de limiter la chose même on
a vu que les italiens ont fait ayant
fait ça ça pas empêché que quelqu'un
venant de la région lombarde est
contaminée quelqu'un en sicile récemment
il ya forcément des trous dans la
raquette
alors c'est là que c'est là que bon dans
les réunions de crise qui se sont tendus
à m qui se sont tenues à matignon le
ministère de l'intérieur était présent
et l'armée étaient présents parce que
bon on a vu que les militaires
interviennent maintenant en italie et
malgré ça il ya quand même les
journalistes qui sont qui ont réussi à
pénétrer à codognan
ce qui est quand même assez surprenant
et cela ils sont pas près d'en sortir
donc le stade d'après c'est ça c'est
encore localisation régionales mais
quand on passe au stade l'épidémie la
maladie c'est un bon il va falloir faire
des choix
parce que même en augmentant le nombre
d'hôpitaux compensant 38 hôpitaux à 70
hôpitaux même en multipliant les
les laboratoires qui auront la
possibilité de faire des tests on va
rapidement être débordées et donc il va
falloir faire des choix dans les
passants on va se prêter lisez en beauce
pu égaliser que les gens qui sont à
risque donc les gens qui ne sont pas à
risque
on va les garder chez eux et donc les
cas simples ça va être pour la médecine
de ville qui va être chargé de
surveiller les patients qui vont rester
chez eux qui vont rester cesser de
confiner qui vont prendre leur
température deux fois par jour qui vont
avoir des contacts répétés avec les
médecins ou les infirmiers mais il faut
que les médecins et les infirmiers
puisse avoir le matériel de protection
nécessaires
or actuellement bien qu'olivier vermand
nous annonce que 40 millions de 2,2 de
masques qui sont en fabrication par mois
on n'a toujours pas vu arriver de
masques il n'y a pas de masque mais je
pense sincèrement que la principale
mesure au vu de ce que je viens de voir
ces derniers jours avec ses patients qui
rentre d'italie qui sont passés par la
zone de piacenza je pense sincèrement
qu'il faut qu'on dispose rapidement de
test pour
pour calmer le jeu très vite donc là le
gouvernement a choisi de doubler ou de
tripler la capacité des laboratoires
mais je pense sincèrement qu'il faut que
les laboratoires de proximité et la
possibilité d'effectuer ces tests et que
ces tests soient effectués dans les
délais très courts donc actuellement on
a les résultats en quatre heures
je pense sincèrement qu'il faut mettre
en place un système où on a un résultat
au maximum dans les six heures pour
éviter la psychose si on a plusieurs cas
si ça commence à s'étendre si ça tousse
plusieurs régions
c'est clair que l'on va passer dans une
autre dimension et on pourra pas
empêcher la psychose